a black woman is suing for white police
officers in a st. Louis suburb for
allegedly assaulting her and her adult
son Marva and Derrick gray were accused
of stealing a television in March from a
Sam's Club
they say they bought the TV earlier in
the day and they had receipts
she says they suffered physical and
emotional injuries from their violent
arrests in an exclusive interview with
Adriana Diaz they said they were
terrified of being killed Marva and
derekgray say they're still traumatized
after this incident with police when
they were accused of stealing a TV late
last night the City of Des Peres
provided CBS News with surveillance
video that shows what happened before
the incident in March the great appeared
to be in an animated discussion with
Sam's Club staff before an officer
enters and reaches for Derrick who pulls
away his 68 year old mother tries to
shield him but then another officer
enters the store and a struggle ensues
with Maher via against the wall and
Derrick slammed to the ground according
to the greys lawsuit earlier that day
Derrick bought the TV for his mother at
the store but when it didn't fit into
his car he returned for it later that's
when a police officer allegedly accused
him of stealing the TV but Derrick was
allowed to leave after a store associate
confirmed the purchase the suit claims
the officer later called in an attempted
theft the Grey's lawyer provided this
receipt to CBS News the gray say they
decided to return the purchase because
of the theft accusation that's when they
say things escalated Derrick says his
head was split open and three of his
teeth were shattered I could not get
over turning around and my son said mom
they are hurting me Mom the incident
ended with gray a security officer being
wheeled out of the store
with his head bandaged he says he is
still in disbelief do you think this was
racially motivated yes
no no doubt yes I know when I'm being
racially profiled attorney Andrew Ames
truth represents the gray family could
it be that there was reason to believe
that your clients were involved in
something well there's there's nothing
that the Grays did to provoke that type
of an attack my thing is if they were a
white older woman and her white son
would that same event have happened I
know about respecting the law but does
the law respect us that's the question
that does seem to be a very good
question that was Adriana Diaz reporting
de pere police say they cannot comment
because of pending litigation because of
pending litigation a statement released
days after the March incidents as
officers were responding to a reported
larceny and upon arrival our officers
were notified that it was the previous
suspects from the earlier incident and
that the items were in fact stolen Marvy
agree currently faces charges herself
including resisting arrest which she
calls
ridiculous Tony that video was very
difficult to watch and I watched mr.
gray and his mother sitting in the way
mr. gray held his head down while his
mother was talking I think it seems
humiliating it was very frightening and
I hope that this is not the end of this
story for these two this is very very
troubling video especially when you hear
that they had a receipt I don't
understand it yeah there were a lot of
off ramps to this conflict it's always a
wonder to me why people don't take those
our friends did not have to go down the
way went down in that video leave it
there